The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: This is how to
randomize two, and what--.
AUDIENCE: Are there slides?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
What we're going to talk about,
it's just recap in case
we missed anything this morning
about the different
methods of introducing an
element of randomization into
your project.
Then I want to talk about the
unit of randomization, whether
you randomize individuals,
or schools,
or clinics, or districts.
If you are very lucky and work
somewhere like Indonesia, Ben
Olken gets to randomize on the
district level of many
hundreds of thousands of
people per unit of
randomization, you need a very
big country to do that.
Multiple treatments, and we'll
go through an example of how
you can design an evaluation
with different treatments to
get at some really underlying
questions, big questions in
the literature or in the
development field, rather than
just does this program work,
but much more of the deep
level questions.
Then I want to talk about
stratification.
And that's something where
actually the theory has
developed a little bit more, and
as Cynthia can attest, it
basically saved our project.
In one case, we thought we just
didn't have enough sample
to do this, but we had
stratified very carefully.
And thank goodness we actually
managed to get a result out of
that project.
And it was only because we did
a good stratification that
that was possible.
So it's definitely worth
thinking about
how to do it correctly.
And then very briefly just talk
about the mechanics of
randomization.
But I think that's actually
best done in the groups.
And we'll also be circulating
and we'll put up on the
website some exercises.
If you actually literally--
I've learned all about
randomization, but how do I
literally do it?
And the answer for
us is normally--
the answer with me is I
get an RA to do it.
[LAUGHTER]
You can write stata code, but
you can also do it in Excel.
So this should be a recap of
what you did this morning, but
I just want to talk about--
I like kind of putting
things in boxes and
seeing pros and cons.
The different kinds of ways of
introducing some element of
randomization into your
project, to be able to
evaluate it: basic lottery, just
some in, some out, some
get the program, some
don't; a phase in.
Can someone explain to
me what a randomized
phase in design is?
Hopefully you did
it this morning.
Does anyone remember what a
randomized phase in design is?
AUDIENCE: Is that the one
where everyone gets
it, but over time?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Everyone gets it in the
end, but you randomize
when they get it.
So some people get it the first
year, some people get it
the second, and that's a very
natural way in which projects
expand over time.
And so you introduce your
element of randomization at
that point and say, well,
who gets it the
first year is random.
Rotation, randomized rotation.
Did Dean talk about that?
AUDIENCE: The way I remember it
is it's almost like phase
in, except for the service goes
away from some people
after a certain point.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So with phase in, you're
building up over time till
everyone gets it.
With rotation, you get it this
year, but then you don't get
it the next year.
Encouragement, an encouragement
design.
OK, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Basically
that treatment--
you use the same word.
You're encouraging people to
apply for a program or to get
the intervention and then
you're comparing all the
people who have access to the
program or the intervention
versus people who don't.
PROFESSOR: You're comparing the
people who were encouraged
to go to the program, where they
may not all actually get
the program, but the ones who
were given this extra special
encouragement or information
about the
program, that's right.
So let's just think about
when those are useful.
How do you decide
which of those--
what are the times when you
might want to use these?
So basic lottery it's very
natural to do when a program
is oversubscribed.
So when you've got a training
course, and more people have
applied for the training
course then
you've got places for.
Again, I'm sure Dean talked
about the fact that that
doesn't mean you have to accept
everyone, whether
they're qualified or not.
You can throw out the people who
aren't qualified and then
just randomize within the people
who are qualified.
And that's OK when it's
politically acceptable for
some people to get nothing.
Sometimes that's OK, sometimes
it isn't OK.
A phase in is a good
design when you're
expanding over time.
You don't have enough capacity
to train everyone the first
year, or get all the programs up
and running the first year,
so you've got to have some phase
in anyway, so why not
randomize the phase in?
And it's also useful when
politically you have to give
something to everyone by the
end of the treatment.
Maybe you are worried
that people won't
cooperate with you.
Maybe you just feel that unless
they're going to get
something at the end, maybe
you feel that it's just
inappropriate not to
treat everyone you
possibly can by the end.
Whatever your reason, if you
feel that you have to give
everyone that you're contacting
something by the
end, then it's a
good approach.
Rotation, again, is useful
when you can't
have a complete control.
Just politically,
it's difficult.
People won't cooperate
with you.
In the Balsakhi example, they
were very nervous that the
schools just weren't going to
let them come in and test the
kids unless they were going to
get something out of it.
So they had to give them all
something at some point, but
you didn't have enough
resources to do
every one by the end.
You only had enough resources
to do half the people.
So you can do half and
then switch, and
then the other half.
Now an encouragement design is
very useful when you can't
deny anyone access
to the program.
So it's been used and discussed
in when you're
setting up a business or former
support centers that
anyone can walk into and use,
you don't want to say, if
someone walks in your door--
you're desperately trying to
drum up custom for this--
somebody walks in the door, you
don't want to say you're
not on our list, go away.
That doesn't make sense
for your program.
Your program is trying
to attract people.
But it might make sense to
spend some extra money to
encourage some particular
people to come
and visit your center.
So it's very useful when
everyone is eligible for the
program, but the take
up isn't very high.
So you've got these centers,
anybody could walk in, but
most people aren't walking in.
If most people are walking in
and using the service anyway,
you got a problem.
Those are going to be very hard
to evaluate, because you
haven't got any margin in
which to change things.
But if take up is currently
low, but everyone is
ineligible, then that's
an opportunity to do
encouragement design.
It's also possible to do when
you've only got two--
I was talking over lunch about
trying to evaluate some
agriculture interventions where
they're setting up two
rice mills in Sierra Leone.
Two is just not enough
to randomize.
You don't want to randomize
where you put
the rice mill anyway.
But you can talk about
encouraging some people or
informing some people that
there's going to be a new
place where they'll be able to
sell rice or get extension
services associated with
the rice mill.
So advantages.
A basic lottery is very
familiar to people.
It's easy to understand.
It's very intuitive.
You're pulling names
out of a hat.
You've got an equal chance
of getting it.
It's very easy to implement,
and you can
implement it in public.
Sometimes it's useful to be
able to show people that
you're being fair.
They see their names going into
the hat, and they see
people pulling them
out of the hat.
Sometimes that's important and
useful to be able to do that.
Again, the phase in is
relatively easy to understand
what's going on.
We're rolling it out, and we're
giving everyone an equal
chance of having it
in the first year.
Don't worry, you'll get it later
on, but you'll have to
wait a little bit.
I understand what I'm
writing here.
Control comply as expect
to benefit.
Oh yes, so the control is going
to comply with you.
They're going to take the
surveys because they know that
they're going to get something
in the end.
So they're willing to keep
talking to you for the three
years because--
So the rotation will give you
more data points than the
phase in, because the problem
with the phase in is over
time, you're running
out controls.
By the end, you don't have
any controls left.
Whereas the rotation, you have
some controls the whole time,
because someone phase out.
Encouragement, as I say, you can
get away with the smaller
sample size.
You can do something even though
you've only got two
rice mills or two business
centers in the
whole of the country.
And you can randomize an
individual level, even when
the program is at a
much bigger level.
But we'll talk more about the
unit of randomization.
You'll see what I mean by
that in a bit more.
So the disadvantages--
I probably should have
kept going along
one line, but anyway--
so a basic lottery is easy to
understand and implement.
The disadvantage is that you've
got a real control, and
the real control doesn't
have any incentive to
cooperate with you.
And sometimes that's a problem
and sometimes it isn't.
I mean, a lot of where I work in
rural Sierra Leone, people
are very happy to
answer surveys.
They don't have very
much else to do.
They like the attention.
Oh, can you come and
survey me too?
But if you're talking about
urban India, there's lots of
other things they
should be doing.
They've got to go get
to their job.
You've got to time the survey
very carefully, otherwise
they're really not going
to want to talk to you.
So you've got to worry a bit
when you have really control
in some areas about differential
attrition.
We'll talk about attrition
later on in the week.
But if you have more people
unwilling to talk to you in
control than you
have treatment,
you have a real problem.
A phrase in, again,
it's very--
as they say, the advantage is
it's very natural to the way
that a lot of organizations
work.
They often expand over time.
But there's a problem of
anticipation of the effects.
So if they know they're going
to get it in two years, that
may change what they're
doing now.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question
about control groups not being
willing to participate?
Are there examples when an
incentive has been used in
order to get people to comply
with the survey?
There's obviously optimal
ways to design that so
you don't ruin the--
PROFESSOR: So sometimes we give
small things, like didn't
you use backpacks?
Little backpacks for
kids in Balsakhi?
GUEST SPEAKER: No, we used
those to actually get our
surveyors to comply.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So sometimes people
give things out.
Normally we don't do that.
Our most recent problem
with it--
and there's also ethical
constraints.
So everything we do
has to go through
human subjects clearance.
And you have to justify if
you're going to give people an
incentive to comply, and
is that going to
change how they respond?
The one case we've had problems
recently which really
screwed us, as Eric can attest
to because he was doing all
the analysis, was people
wouldn't comply to get their
hemoglobin checked, which
required a pin
prick taking blood.
And then the people in the
treatment were more willing to
give blood than the people in
the control, and that caused
us a lot of problems.
But I think probably human
subjects saying, we'll pay you
to take your blood, we've
had trouble there.
But I think if you're worrying
about time and things, and
kind of snacks, if it takes a
long time, and you want people
to come into centers to do
experiments and games.
Sometimes people use games as
a way of getting an outcome
measure, and that takes quite
a lot of time to get them to
play all these different
games and see how
they're playing them.
And then providing food at the
testing is kind of a very
natural, and I think nobody's
going to complain about that.
And it helps make sure
that people come in.
In the US, it's actually
very common to pay
people to submit surveys.
So you give them a voucher,
you'll get a voucher if you
fill in the survey.
I'm not used to doing surveys
in the US, but I know my
colleagues who do it in the US
will pay to get people to send
in surveys.
So there's a bit of a cultural
thing about what's the
appropriate way to do this.
So as I say, with the phase in,
you have to worry about
anticipation of effects.
And again, this really depends
on what you're measuring,
whether this is going
to be a problem.
If you're looking at
accumulation of capital or
savings, or buying a durable,
if you know you're going to
get money next year, then it'll
effect whether you buy
something this year.
Where as if it's going to
school, you're not going to
wait till next year to go
to school probably.
So you have to think about
it in the context
of what you're doing.
The other real problem with
a phase in is it's very
difficult to get long
term effects.
Why is it difficult to get
a long term effect
in a phase in design?
AUDIENCE: Because within a short
period of time, everyone
has the treatment, and therefore
it's hard to tell
the difference between control
and treatment phase.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Because we are looking 10 years
out, you're looking at
someone who's had it for nine
years versus 10 years.
Whereas if you want the 10 year
effective of a project,
you really want somebody to have
not got it for 10 years
versus to have got
it for 10 years.
So that can often be the
complete death knell to using
a phase in.
The one exception to that is if
you've got a school program
or a kind of age cohort, then
you phase it in over time.
Some people will just missed
it because they
will have moved on.
So one of our longest horizon
projects is actually a phase
in project, which is the
deworming, because they're
managing to follow up the
cohorts who had left school by
the time it reached
their school.
So it's not always impossible,
but it's something you really
have to think about.
Encouragement design, this
you'll talk about more in the
analysis session.
You always have to think
about what's the
question that I'm answering.
And with an encouragement
design, you're answering the
question, what's the effect of
the program on people who
respond to the incentive?
Because some people are
responding to the
incentive to take up.
Some people are already doing
it without the incentive.
Some people won't do it even
with the incentive.
When you're measuring the
impact, you're measuring the
impact on the kind of person who
responds to the incentive,
who's not your average person.
Now maybe that's exactly
who you want to be
measuring the effect on.
Because if you're looking at a
program that might encourage
people to do more, say you're
looking at savings and you've
got an encouragement to come to
a meeting of a 401k plan,
and that encourages them to take
up a 401k plan, that's
kind of exactly the people
you're interested in, who's a
marginal 401k participant.
In other cases, you're more
interested in kind of the
average effect of a program.
So again, you have to
worry about that.
You need a big enough
inducement to
really change take up.
If you change it a little bit,
you're not going to have
enough statistical power
to measure the effect.
We'll talk about statistical
power tomorrow.
The other thing you have to
worry about is are you
measuring the effect of taking
up the program, or are you
measuring the effect of the
incentive to take it up?
If you do a really big incentive
to take it up, that
might have a direct effect.
So there's no right answer as
to which is the best design.
It completely depends on
what your project is.
And hopefully this is what
you're learning this week, is
which of these is suitable
to my particular
problem and my situation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you explain what
the control group would
be in the encouragement, and
how would you gather
information about the
control group?
PROFESSOR: So the control group
in the encouragement is
the people who weren't given the
encouragement to attend.
There's an example on our
website of the 401k plan, and
they're looking at what's
the impact on--
they wanted to answer, if you
take up a 401k plan, does it
just shift your saving from one
kind of asset to another
kind of asset?
Or does it actually totally
increase your savings?
So they needed some variation.
They weren't going to be able
to randomly persuade this
company to have a 401k.
Nobody is going to decide
whether to have a 401k plan in
their company based on
the toss of the coin.
It's too important
of a decision.
However, you will find that a
lot of companies, a lot of
universities--
and this was done within
a university context--
a lot of the eligible people
are not signed up.
So they took the list of all
the people who are eligible
who had not signed up and
randomly sent letters to some
of them saying--
I think maybe even a monetary
encouragement--
to come to the meeting, where
they learned about 401k plan.
More of those people ended up
signing up for a 401k plan
than the people who had
not received a letter.
Some of the people who had not
received a letter did sign up.
But fewer of them signed up
than the people who had
received an encouragement to
attend the meeting and sign up
for a 401k plan.
So all you need is
a difference.
More of the people in the
treatment group sign up, the
control group are the people
who are not encouraged.
And there were fewer of
them who signed up.
As long as there's
a difference.
In our microfinance example, we
have in our treatment areas
where microfinance is offered,
but it's not actually like we
can say, you are taking
microfinance, you are not.
We can only offer it.
It's available, and then people
have to sign up for it.
We have some difference-- not
a huge difference, but some
difference in the percentage
of people who were offered
microfinance who take it up
versus those in areas where
they were not offered it.
So all long as there's some
difference there, you can
statistically tease
out the effect.
And it's random whether
you're offered.
It's not random whether
you take it up.
It's random whether
you're offered.
And you'll learn in the analysis
section how you
actually cope with the analysis
when not everyone
takes it up, but some
people take it up.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How was that
a nontrivial finding?
More people that you market
a 401k to will sign up?
PROFESSOR: No, no, that's
not the finding.
The finding is using the fact
that more people who are
marketed to sign up, you can
then look at how their savings
behavior changed.
Did they just shift money out of
their other savings and put
it in the 401, or did it
actually lead to an increase
in total savings?
And that's kind of the
fundamental policy question
about 401ks, does giving tax
preference to savings, does it
increase total savings, or is it
just move your savings from
one kind of instrument
to another?
And you look on average at the
people who were offered, do
they have totally more savings
versus the people who were not
encouraged to do 401ks?
And then basically you adjust
for the number of people who
actually took up.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: This subject has been
brought up a couple times
so far, but I'm still
confused on.
You say within the
disadvantages, there's the
problem that you're going to
measure the impact of those
who respond to the incentive.
And this seems like a major
disadvantage, that it puts in
a lot of selection bias, because
whoever is responding
to the incentive.
So what has been brought up so
far is that you then look at
the intended treatment rather
than the treatment itself, but
I still don't understand--.
PROFESSOR: OK, so you're going
to do intend to treat versus
treatment on the treated
on Friday.
So the actual mechanics
of how you do it,
we're putting it off.
You're not meant to be able to
do it yet, because you have a
whole hour and a half on that.
AUDIENCE: But if you then
do that, then does
that selection disappear?
PROFESSOR: No.
So you said you're worried
about selection bias, the
people who are going
to show up.
It's not that we measure the
outcomes of those who sign up
versus all the control.
We measure, on average, the
effect of all the people who
are offered the treatment versus
the average of all the
people who were not offered.
So on average treatment versus
control where treatment is
being offered, not taking up.
So we have no selection bias.
If we see a change, we assume
that all that change comes
from the few people who
actually changed their
behavior as a result
of the incentive.
So say half the people take up
and we see a change of 2%.
If all the 2% is coming from
just half the people changing
their behavior, then we assume
that the change in behavior
there was 4%.
Because it's coming from half
the sample, and averaged over
everyone it's 2%, so if it's
only coming from half, they
must have changed by 4%.
So that's what you
do, very simply.
It's not a selection bias
because we're taking the
averages of two completely
equivalent groups.
But we are taking it
from the change in
behavior of certain people.
And so what we are measuring is
how the program changed the
behavior of those
certain people.
So it's not selection
bias, it's just
what are you measuring.
Who's changing?
Who are you looking at?
It's just like saying if you
do the project in the
mountains, you're getting the
impact of doing the project in
the mountains, whereas it may
not tell you about what's the
effect of doing it
on the plains.
AUDIENCE: It's the external
validity, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
external validity.
But it really depends
on the question.
You can't say that's
right or wrong.
Because if your question is what
happens to people who are
in the mountains, then that's
the right answer.
If you want to know what happens
to people in the
plains, then you have to think
about does this make sense?
In this case it's changing the
effect on the marginal person
who responds to incentive.
If that's the very poor who
respond to the incentive, then
you know the effect of doing the
program on the very poor.
And maybe that's what
you want to know.
But as long as you know what
the question is that you're
answering, I think
that's important.
Then you can think about
whether it makes sense,
whether you've got an external
validity question or whether--
you care about the poor
anyway, so I'm happy.
So I've taken half an hour
on one slide, so I should
probably speed up.
So unit and randomization.
We just went over an awful lot
material in that slide, so
it's quite fundamental.
So I'm glad you asked
questions about it.
So the unit of randomization is
are we going to randomize
individuals to get the program,
or are we going to
randomize communities to get the
program, or a group level?
It could be a school,
a community, a
health center, a district.
But it's a clump of people.
So how do we make a decision
about what unit
to randomize at?
So if we do it at an individual
level, you get the
program, you don't get the
program, you get the program,
we can do a really nice,
detailed evaluation at a
relatively small cost.
That's the benefit.
But it may be politically
difficult to do that.
To have different treatments
within one community,
particularly if you're
thinking--
imagine if you were in
a school context, and
you've got a class.
And you say, well,
you get a lunch.
We're providing lunch to
you, but I'm sorry, you
don't get any lunch.
It's just very hard to do that,
and often inappropriate
to do that.
And what's more, it often
doesn't work, because most
kids, when they're given
something and their neighbor
isn't, they all share
with their neighbor.
At least most kids in developing
countries, maybe
not my kids.
And then you've just totally
screwed up your evaluation.
Because if they're sharing with
their neighbor, who's the
control, you don't know what the
effect of having lunch is,
because actually there isn't any
difference between them.
So that's not going to work.
So sometimes a program can
only be implemented at a
certain level.
There's just kind of logistical
things which mean
we're setting up a center
in a community.
We don't set it up for
individuals, we set up one in
the community.
So we either do it
or we don't.
So that often gives you the
answer right there as to
what's the unit that you
can randomize at.
Spillovers is exactly what we
were talking about in terms of
sharing the food.
Sitting next to someone
who gets the
treatment may impact you.
And if it does, you have to take
that into account when
you design what unit that
you're going to do the
evaluation at.
So as they say, encouragement
is this kind of weird thing
that's halfway between the two,
in the sense that the
program may be implemented at
a village or district level,
but you can randomize
encouragement to take it up at
an individual level.
So sometimes that's a nice
way out of that.
So multiple treatments is
sometimes people list as kind
of an alternative method
of randomization.
But really, you can have any of
these different approaches
could be done with multiple
treatments or with one treatment.
Now I'm going to take a little
time to kind of work through a
couple of different examples
that are all
based around schools.
I don't know why.
My last lecture was all
based around schools.
I guess you had Dean talking
about different examples in
the last lecture.
So going back to the Balsakhi
case and thinking about the
problems that came out,
and the issues around
the Balsakhi case.
We're going to look at two
different approaches to
answering some of those
questions, and sort of discuss
what are the pros and cons
of the different
ways of doing it.
So the fundamental issues, if
we think about the needs
assessment around Balsakhi, what
were the problems in the
needs assessment?
You had very large
class sizes.
You had children at different
levels of learning.
You had teachers who
were often absent.
And you had curricula that were
inappropriate for many of
the kids, particularly the
most marginalized kids.
This was urban India, pretty
similar problems in many
developing countries.
Most places I've worked
have that problem,
all of those problems.
So what are the different
interventions that we could do
to address those issues?
We could have more teaches,
and that would allow us to
split the classes into
smaller classes.
If we're worrying about children
being at different
levels of learning, we could
stream pupils, i.e.
divide the classes such that
you have people who are of
more similar ability
in each class.
How do we cope with teachers
often being absent?
You could make teachers
more accountable, and
they may show up more.
How do we cope with the
curricula being often
inappropriate for the most
marginalized children?
Well, you might want to change
the curricula and make it more
basic or more focused on where
the children actually are at.
All too often the curricula
appear to be set according to
what the kids of the Minister
of Education, their level
rather than what's the
appropriate level for kids in
poor schools.
So how did the Balsakhi study
approach those questions and
try and answer those
questions?
The Balsakhi was limited
in the fact that
they had one treatment.
So it's going to be a little
more complicated to tease out
all of those different
questions, because this is
going back to the question you
discussed before, which is
we've got a package
of interventions.
They had a package which was
the Balsakhi program.
And they managed to get
an awful lot of
information out of that.
And then we'll look at an
alternative that looks at
multiple treatments and is able
to get at these questions
in a somewhat more
precise way.
So in the Balsakhi study you've
got this package, which
is that each school in the
treatment got a Balsakhi a
tutor in grades three or four.
The lowest achieving children in
the class were sent to the
Balsakhi for half the day, and
all the children at the end
were given a test.
So that was the design
of the project.
Now we're going to go through
the questions that we want to
try and answer.
The first question is do smaller
class sizes improve
test scores?
So as you went through in the
case, even though it was one
project and it was designed--
one study and it was designed
to test the effectiveness of
the Balsakhi program, they
actually were able to answer
this question to some extent by
saying, the kids who were
at a high level at the beginning
didn't get these
other elements of Balsakhi.
All they got was that the low
ability kids were moved out of
their class.
So they actually had smaller
class sizes as a result for
half of the day.
So that gives us a chance
to look at does
lower class sizes help?
So you just compare the high
achieving pupils in treatment
and control, some of those in
the treatment classes had
smaller class sizes
for half the day;
those without did not.
Now another question that we had
on our list is does having
an accountable teacher
get better results?
So we're worried about teaches
not showing up.
If you make the teacher more
accountable, do they show up
more often, and do you
get better results?
Now in this case, the Balsakhi
is more accountable than the
regular teacher, because the
Balsakhi is hired by an NGO.
They can be fired if they're
not doing their job.
But the other teacher is a
government teacher, and as we
know, government teaches are
very rarely fired, whether in
developing countries or
developed countries, whether
they're doing a good
job or not.
So we could look at the
treatment effect for low
versus high children.
What do I mean by the
treatment effect?
What do I mean by that,
comparing the treatment effect
for low versus higher
achieving children?
AUDIENCE: Maybe the result
of the test scores.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so we're going
to use the test scores.
But the treatment effect is
whose test scores am I
comparing to get the
treatment effect
for low scoring children?
AUDIENCE: The one with the
government teacher versus the
one with Balsakhi teacher?
PROFESSOR: So all the
low scoring people
are going to be--
if they're in treatment, they'll
get the Balsakhi.
Right?
Yes, so it's--
I see what you mean.
You're right.
So what we're saying is what's
the effect of the treatment
for low scoring?
That means compare the test
score improvement for the low
performing kids in treatment
with the low performing kids
in control.
That's the treatment effect.
What was the effect
of the treatment?
Compare treatment and control
for low scoring kids.
The difference is the
treatment effect.
So what's the difference between
treatment and control
for low versus the treatment
effect for high scoring kids?
So basically all of the kids
in the treatment group got
smaller class sizes.
Only the initially low scoring
kids got the Balsakhi, got the
accountable teacher.
So if you look at the high
scoring kids, you get just the
effect of class size.
If you look at just the low
scoring kids, you get class
size, lower class size, and
accountable teacher.
You also get a different
curriculum.
So you've got three changes.
One of the changes we've taken
care of, because we've looked
at that on its own.
We've got smaller class sizes on
its own by looking at just
high scoring kids.
So the two left are changing
curricula and
changing kind of teacher.
And that's the difference
between the treatment effect
for low and the treatment effect
for high scoring kids.
So as I say, you've got two
things going on for the low
scoring kids.
You've got three things going
on, but we've controlled for
one of them.
The two things that are
different about the low
scoring kids is they get a
different kind of teacher and
they get a different
kind of curricula.
So it's going to be really hard
to tease out those two
things from each other.
So does streaming improve
test scores?
We can look at what happens to
the high scoring kids, because
they don't have--
we don't have to worry about the
fact that they're changing
the kind of teacher, because
they've still got the
government teacher.
All they've got is the low
scoring kids taken out of
their class.
So we could look at the
high scoring kids.
Now they found nothing.
And that makes it easier to
interpret, because if you
don't find anything, and there's
more streaming, they
haven't got the low scoring
kids in their class, and
they've got smaller
class sizes.
So they didn't find anything.
So they said, well, smaller
class sizes didn't help and
streaming didn't help.
But if they'd found a small
effect, they wouldn't have
known whether it was
this or this.
Because lots of things are being
changed, and they've
only got one treatment.
That's basically what
I'm trying to say.
They managed to tease out a lot,
but they can't nail down
everything, because they're
changing lots of different
things about the classroom, but
they've only got treatment
versus control.
So if they got a zero and two
things going on, they can
actually say, well, both
of them must be zero.
Unless of course, one helped and
one hurt and they exactly
offset each other.
Again, focusing on basic
improvements, focusing the
curricula, as we say, for the
low scoring kids, there was an
improvement, but we don't know
whether it was because the
teacher was more accountable
or the curricula changed.
We can maybe look at teacher
attendance and see did that
change a lot, in which case if
it didn't, if the Balsakhi
didn't turn up more than the
regular teacher, then it's
probably the curricula
that's going up.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it methodologically
sound to
compare side by side the
treatment effect for low
achieving students and high
achieving students, even
though they're starting in
very different places?
Can you make them comparable
because they're starting at
such different levels, and it
might be more difficult to get
from one level than
from another?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So again, you can't judge where
low scoring kids improve
by 10%, high scoring kids
improve by 15%.
Is one really bigger than the
other, or is it just the way
you measure it?
Is it harder to get high scoring
kids up or easier?
Then you're in trouble.
But in this case, the high
scoring kids didn't see any
improvement at all.
So that's kind of easier to
interpret, whereas the low
scoring kids saw a huge
amount of improvement.
You could say, well, it's just
hard to get the high scoring
kids much better.
But when we say high scoring
kids, we're like they're on
grade level.
They're not massively
behind grade level.
It's not like they're such
superstars that there's no
improvement possible.
They were just on grade level.
That's all we mean by high
scoring in this context.
It wasn't that they were
desperately falling behind.
But as I say, you don't want to
compare an improvement of
10 versus an improvement in 15,
because that depends on
how you scored the test.
So it's hard to interpret.
But in this case, the program
just didn't help the top.
And in the textbook example that
I talked about before,
giving textbooks just didn't
help the average kid.
It only helped the top 20%.
And then I think you
can say something.
Again, it's pointing you to
the fact that maybe the
curricula is just so
over their heads.
If you don't see any movement
in the bottom 80% from a
program, and you only see
movement in the top, then you
can say something.
Again, remember though my
comment that you should say in
advance what it is you're
looking for.
That you care about this,
because you don't want to dice
it every percentile.
The 56th percentile, it really
worked for them.
It didn't work for anybody
else, but the
56th percentile really--
well, that's not very
convincing.
But if you've got a story that
I'm worried about the
curricula being appropriate, and
it's really the kids who
are falling behind who are going
to benefit most, and
this is the intervention
designed for them, then it's
completely appropriate to
be looking at does this
intervention actually help the
kids it was designed to help,
which are the low
achieving kids?
That basic question
is appropriate.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: This is a
little off topic.
In our group we were reviewing
this, we talked about criteria
for determining a low achieving
student, and that
that was not based on anything
quantitative necessarily, that
that was sort of a more
discretionary choice on the
part of the teacher.
But in fact, the thing that
you used to evaluate the
efficacy of intervention
at the end was a test.
And it was a pretest.
So I'm just curious about
the test itself.
Was this a specially designed
test by you?
Was this something that
the NGO already had?
Were students familiar with
this kind of a test?
PROFESSOR: It was a test that
was designed to pick out
people who were falling
behind the curricula.
And the idea of the program was
that we want to pull out
the kids who are really falling
behind the curricula.
So it was a test designed to
pick out the people that they
thought would benefit from the
program, and the things that
they were targeting
in the program.
You're right that in a sense
it would've been more
effective to say, we'll
decide based on the
test which kids go.
This test is designed to figure
out who's going to
benefit from the program,
who's the target
group for the program.
We'll tell the teachers these
are the kids that
you should pull out.
But I guess it was just seen
that in this context, the
teachers have a lot
of control.
And it was seen that they needed
to make that decision.
Now in the end, they could see
whether the kids that were
pulled out were in fact
the ones who scored
lowly on the test.
It wasn't a complete match,
but it was a decent match.
So this wouldn't make any sense
if there wasn't some
comparison comparative between
those two, if it wasn't a
pretty good predictor of
who got the program.
AUDIENCE: Did you develop
it, or had they
already developed it?
GUEST SPEAKER: Pratham
had developed it.
PROFESSOR: So it
was the NGO--.
GUEST SPEAKER: Pratham hired
them on the school curriculum.
So they basically went through
the textbook of the grades
three and four--
actually on grades two and
three, and included questions
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
AUDIENCE: And they did that
specifically for the purposes
of this study?
Or was this part of their
program, but it just wasn't
the main criteria
for the study?
GUEST SPEAKER: They were
testing people
independent of the study.
But I think in this particular
instance, this test was
designed at the same
time as the study.
PROFESSOR: They've since
actually developed another
tool which we now use in a lot
of other places, which is a
very, very basic tool for seeing
basically can you read.
And it's a very nice tool for
sorting the very bottom.
Because a lot of education tests
are all aimed at the
top, and they don't sort out
the bottom half of the
distribution.
And Pratham's developed a very
nice test, which they now
introduce in--
they do a nationwide testing
of kids across India.
And they have a very good
mapping of where a kid's
falling behind.
And it's a test that's really
designed to get at the bottom.
We now use it when I was doing
a study in Bangladesh.
And people in the World
Bank are using
it to do it in Africa.
It's called a dipstick because
it can be done quite quickly,
but it gives you quite a good,
accurate indication of where
people are going.
So that was kind
of complicated.
We're having trouble sorting out
exactly what was going on
in different--
although we get a very clear
idea of does the program work,
and we know it works.
If we want to try to get at
these fundamental ideas, we
got some sense from it,
but it's a little
hard to get at precisely.
So how can we do a better job
of really nailing these
fundamental issues that
we want to get at?
Well, the alternative is that
the old economics thing if you
want to get four outcomes, you
got to have four instruments.
So do smaller classes
improve test scores?
Well what's the obvious
way to do that?
You just do a treatment
that adds teachers.
Does accountable teachers
get better results?
You make the new teachers more
accountable, and you randomize
whether a kid gets a smaller
class with an accountable
teacher, or a smaller class
with the old teacher, you
randomize that.
So you can test the new teachers
who are accountable
versus the regular teachers
that were not accountable.
Does streaming improve
test scores?
Well, you do that separately
with the different treatment.
In some schools, you divide
classes into ability
groupings, and in other
schools, you just
randomly mix them.
And you've got an opportunity
to do that division because
you've just added some
more teachers.
But you randomize so some
schools get the division,
unlike the Balsakhi, where
all the classes
got divided by ability.
This case sometimes they will
be and sometimes they won't,
and then we've got more
variation, and we can pick up
those things more precisely.
Does focusing the basics
improve results?
Well, you can train some people
to focus on the basics
and only introduce those
in some schools.
This is an actual project did
the first three of these.
If you wanted to do this
one, you'd have
to add another treatment.
So extra teacher provision in
Kenya, at least one of those
involved in Balsakhi went off
and did it again with more
schools and more treatments.
Esther was part of both
of these projects.
So they started with a target
population of 330 schools.
Some of them were randomized
into pure control group, no
extra teacher, exactly as
they were doing before.
Another bunch much more, and
you'll realize why, because
I'm about to subdivide this into
many other things, got an
extra teacher.
And that extra teacher was
a contract teacher, i.e.
they could be fired if
they didn't show up.
So then you split it into those
who are streamed, i.e.
they are grouped by ability when
they're segregated into
the different classes,
and those who--
I shouldn't say ability, I
should say achievement--
versus those who are
just randomly
divided between classes.
There's no attempt to stream.
Within that you've got
your extra teachers.
Some of them are contract
teachers, some of them not.
So you need to randomize which
classes get the government
teacher and which get the
contract teacher.
What would happen if you didn't
insist on that being
randomized?
Well no actually, that's
fine, because these
classes are the same.
But when I go here, we've got
some of the classes are
grouped to be the low
level learning
when they enter school.
In Kenya, this was done by
whether you knew any English,
because all the teaching is
in English in school.
So there were some kids who
were turning up in school
knowing some English and some
kids turning up who have no
words of English.
So the idea is, that's kind of
the fundamental thing when you
start school.
You're talking to a bunch of
people, some of whom know
English and some don't,
can you adapt your
teaching level to that?
And this allows them to adapt
their teaching to whether the
kids in the class know
any English or not.
So some are grouped.
So these are all grouped
by ability.
You've got the lower level of
English learning at the
beginning and the higher
level of English
learning at the beginning.
Now, if I didn't randomize, so
some of these got government
teachers and--
or contract teachers, and some
of these got government
teachers versus contact
teachers.
If I didn't insist
on randomizing
this, what would happen?
What would I fear would happen,
and why would that
screw up my ability to do
the evaluation properly?
If I just sorted they by the
level of scoring on English at
the beginning, and then said
OK, you've got contract
teachers, you've got government
teachers, you
figure out who teaches
which class.
What would I worry
about happening?
AUDIENCE: They would assign
teachers in a systematic way,
and you wouldn't be able to
determine whether the effects
were due to the tracking,
or because we
got the better teacher.
PROFESSOR: Right.
My guess is all the higher level
classes would be taken
by the government teacher, and
all the lower classes would be
given to the contract teacher.
And then I wouldn't know whether
it was streaming works
for high level but not for low
level or vice versa, or
whether it's something to
do with the teacher.
I have to take control and say,
you're only doing this if
I get to decide which class
is taken by which teacher.
But this way we know that half
of the lower level kids got
taken by a government teacher,
half of them
by a contract teacher.
Which classes it was
was randomized.
Because otherwise I'm going to
get all the low ones being--
or most of the low ones being
taken by the contract teacher,
most of the high ones
being taken by
the government teacher.
And I've got two things going
on, and only one difference
that I can't sort
out the effects.
AUDIENCE: If the interest is
to determine the effect of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: But I'm not.
What I'm--
lots of clicks involved.
What were my questions
at the beginning?
Oh dear.
I'm trying to identify things
to deal with all of these.
And I'm trying to identify a
bunch of different things.
I'm trying to identify
what's the effect of
smaller class sizes?
I'm also worrying that children
in these big classes
are at different levels.
So I also want to answer
what's the effect
of streaming kids?
So that's our--
I agree.
It's a whole separate
question.
And I'm describing a design of
an evaluation that does not
answer one question.
It answers three questions.
This particular one didn't
answer this one.
So three questions that-- so one
evaluation with multiple
treatments is designed to answer
three of, I would argue
three of the most fundamental
questions in education.
How important a class size?
How important is
it to deliver--
to have coherent classes that
are all at the same level so
that you can deliver a
message that's at the
level of the children?
And how important is it to make
teachers accountable?
Those are three completely
different questions.
The Balsakhi was getting some
answers to these, but they
only changed one thing.
They only had one program, so
it was hard to tease out.
So we're designing this
to answer those
three different questions.
So you're right.
If you just want to answer
what's the effect of adding
teaches, you don't need such
a complicated design.
But they also wanted to answer
what's the most effective way
of adding more teachers, or
alternatively, just what's a
better way of organizing
a school?
Does this improve the
way the school works
to do it this way?
And then you see that
we've got--
that's why we started with
lots more schools in this
group, because we're dividing
it more times, and we need
these different.
So how are we going to actually
look at the results
to be able to answer
this question?
So the first hypothesis we
have is providing extra
teachers leads to better
educational outcomes.
Just smaller class sizes, better
So to answer that question, we
simply compare all the people
who are in this group with all
the people who are in control.
That's the comparison when we
do the analysis, we do that.
Our secondary thing is, is it
more important to have smaller
class sizes for lower
performing kids?
Are they the ones who
benefit most?
And then we can look at
the low performing
kids in these groups.
This is a subgroup analysis
saying, is the program effect
different for different
kinds of kids?
Is this kind of approach most
important for people who start
at a given level?
So that's relatively simple.
Our second hypothesis is
students in classes grouped by
ability perform better on
average than those in mixed
level classes.
So this is exactly the second
question, which is, I agree, a
completely separate question.
And that, we don't
look at this one.
Because these have a different
class size, so you don't want
to throw them in with this
lot, because then you're
changing two things at once.
You take all of those who have
smaller class sizes, some who
are mixed ability, and some who
are split by the level of
attainment when they come in.
And a big question in the
education literature is, maybe
it's good for high performing
kids to be separated out, but
maybe that actually hurts
low performing kids.
So they were able
to look at that.
Actually they found that both
low performing at the baseline
and high performing at the
baseline, both did better
under streaming than under
mixed classes.
Their argument being that
those who are in the low
performing group
were actually--
their teacher could teach to
their level and they did
better as a result.
Now the other question we have
is, is it better to--?
AUDIENCE: Just a point
of interest.
That's a very different
conclusion than
has been found here.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because the biggest
educational research study
here found the Coleman
effect, the benefit
to the poorer kids.
So it's interesting why in a
developing country it would be
so different.
PROFESSOR: I don't know
the answer to that.
It was interesting that
virtually everything they
found was opposite to
what you find in the
developed country example.
So class size did not
have an effect.
Well, the class size evidence
is somewhat mixed.
But a lot of the more recent
stuff, the randomized class
size ones, I think, have
found class size--
you probably know the--
Mike, you know the US education
literature better than me.
But my understanding is a lot of
the recent stuff has found
class size affects in the US.
But now, some people argue it
only helps if you bring it
down below 20.
And they're bringing
it from 100 to 50.
And a lot of educationalists
will say, well, there's no
point, because unless you give
individual attention, and you
can't give individual
attention at 50.
You've got to bring
it way down.
So there's another question
about these things could be
very different in how
much you would do.
You can't just say class
size doesn't matter.
It may matter over some ranges
and not over other ranges.
But in terms of a practical
proposal, these countries
aren't going to get
down to below 20.
So they're arguing about should
we get it down from 100
to 50, and it doesn't seem
to have a very big
effect in this context.
What does have an effect is the
streaming, and also which
teacher you have; whether you
have an accountable teacher.
So the accountable teacher, the
contract teachers who have
less experience, almost
as much training
actually in this context.
In the Balsakhi case, the
contract teachers had less
training than government
teachers, still performed
amazingly; were the ones
who saw the really big
improvements.
But here, the contract teachers
are basically people
who are trained and waiting to
become a government teacher,
but haven't--
they've trained lots of
government teachers, but they
haven't got any places
for them.
So they're mainly the people
who are taking up these
contracts did much better,
much higher test scores.
You see here, we've got three
different boxes with contract
teachers, and three different
boxes of government.
And we can pool all of these
together to make the
comparison.
Why can we do that?
Because some of them have lower
class sizes and some of
them don't.
But these have higher class
sizes and these have higher
class sizes.
So the ones with higher class
sizes are in both treatment
and control, so we're fine.
The average class size in all
this red box is the same as
the average class size
in all this red box.
We could pool all of them
together, which helps a lot on
our sample size, because you
remember there are only about
55 in each one of these.
AUDIENCE: What exactly
was the criteria for
the contract teacher?
What's their contract
based on?
PROFESSOR: So their contract
is with the local NGO who
hires them.
They have a whole other cross
cutting thing which I haven't
got into, which is some
of the communities--
so they were hired by the
community actually, with
funding from an NGO.
They were responsible
to the community.
And sometimes the communities
were given extra training to
help them oversee these
teachers and
sometimes they weren't.
But they're contracted in the
sense, if you get a job with
the government, it's for life.
And these guys can be terminated
at any time.
AUDIENCE: Would they
be terminated
based on test stores?
PROFESSOR: No.
So the main thing that's
going on here is that
these guys show up.
AUDIENCE: Oh I see,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's just like
they actually--
AUDIENCE: If you didn't show
up, you would get fired?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So it's not like you've got to
have an improvement of 10% in
your test scores.
No, it's like maybe if they like
severely beat the kids
regularly, or got known for
raping the kids, which is
actually relatively
common, that might
get them into trouble.
But mainly the issue here is
that they showed up, because
they knew that if they didn't
show up on a regular basis,
they'd be fired.
And that seems to be the big
thing that's going on.
Interestingly, the cross cutting
thing I talked about,
we're looking at training
the communities to
oversee these teachers.
Sometimes when you've got the
contract teacher showing up,
the government teacher
showed up less.
So sorry, I was saying
about class size.
We don't have lower class
size, but we do have
differences in these in terms
of whether they're split
randomly or streamed.
So there are other differences
going on between these
different boxes, but they all
have the same class size.
And on average, they all
have the same thing.
On average, all the other
characteristics are similar
between these two groups.
Sometimes the government teacher
saw there was an extra
teacher, so they showed
up even less than
in this pure control.
But where you had the community
trained to oversee
them, that actually
happened less.
So that was the one benefit of
giving help to the community
to oversee, because the contract
teacher said look,
the community's breathing
down my neck.
I'm meant to be teaching
this class.
I can't always be teaching
your class as well.
But I'm just stunned in terms
of the education literature.
In all the work that we've done,
this is just the first
order problem.
Just showing up is just
one of the first
order problems in education.
And in health too.
Health is even worse.
Fewer health workers show up
than teachers show up in any
country we've ever studied.
So that's not very complicated,
it's just that
they actually do their job.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you parse out
what [UNINTELLIGIBLE] the
government teachers sometimes
show up even less?
So there's no counter-factual--?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because you've
got government teachers
here, in the pure control.
They are all government
teachers.
Now they have a bigger class
size, but you can compare the
government teachers here with
the government teachers here.
And indeed, that's what's
giving you your--
a pure class size effect
without changing
accountability, you would look
at this versus this.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
problems that spill over when
the government teacher doesn't
turn up, so the contract
teacher has to teach
both classes?
PROFESSOR: In a sense,
that's just the
program effect, right?
It's not a spill over to the
control, because these are all
within the fact that then--
it's not like they're then
showing up more to some
control over here.
So a spillover is when you have
an effect on the control.
But these aren't in the
control, they're
between these two.
But that's the effect of having
a contract teacher.
When you have a contract
teacher, you've got to take
into account that it may
change the effect.
It may change what the
government teacher does.
So it's not going to be
effective if it totally
reduces what a government
teaches does.
AUDIENCE: But wouldn't it limit
your ability to compare
across your different
treatments?
Because if you've got--
please go back to
the last slide--
it influences your class size.
Because if I've got a contract
teacher who's now having to do
the work of a government teacher
too, what were two
classrooms have now effectively
become one, so it
is a spillover in
that that is now
behaving like your control.
PROFESSOR: Well, when you look
at the class size effect,
you're looking at here,
between these two.
And what you're saying is, you
think you've halved class size
by having twice as
many teachers.
But actually you haven't, but
you take into account when
you're comparing that.
So you're saying you're
doubling the number of
teachers, but the class size is
improving by less than that
slightly, because you've
got more absenteeism.
But on the other hand, if you're
looking at the program,
is this a good thing to do?
That's part of what it is.
So in all of these cases, when
you write it up and you
explain what's going on, you
don't just show the numbers,
you explain this is
the mechanism.
And you're measuring all that
you were talking about before
in terms of the theory of change
and measuring each step
along the way.
Then why is it we think
is going on.
And then you can see, as I say,
if you've got this other
design of looking at which--
another treatment that actually
managed to keep the
two classes more separate
than what's--
what do we see in those versus
the ones that weren't able to
keep the two separate.
It wasn't that they
never showed up.
It was just that they
did see that--
and it is important.
What I would call that is
a kind of unintended
consequences, and that just
emphasizes the fact that you
really need to be thinking about
what are some of the
potential unintended
consequences of what you're
doing, so that you can measure
them and make sure that you
pick them up.
And then if it doesn't work,
maybe it's because of that.
And then what can you do to
offset that, and hopefully
maybe you have another
treatment that
tries to offset that.
So then you can say, is it more
effective in those ones
where you've got tracking
or not?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are government
teachers assigned in the same
manner within the community,
where usually if you're
training, you'd stay in
the same community?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
how large
these communities are.
But if you're comparing somebody
who was drawn from a
community, like a contractor
was drawn from a community,
and I understand you're mostly
focusing on absenteeism, not
the ability of the teacher.
But if the teacher is drawn from
the same community as the
contract teacher, or the
government teachers are
randomized, is there any way
you could have some sort of
bias situation there?
Because if you're from the
same community, maybe you
consistently get--.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's be really
careful when we bandy around
the word bias, because bias
means something specific.
So this is I think what you're
talking about is, be careful
that you're understanding what
it is that's generating the
difference between the contract
teachers and the
government teachers.
I'm saying that it's the fact
that they're accountable and
they can be fired.
But it may also be
that they're more
local to the area.
They may live--
or not live, because they all
live in the area now, but they
are originally from that
community, and that may make
them more likely to be more
responsive to the
needs of the community.
So it's not just that they can
be fired, it's that they know
people in the community, and
they're more responsive.
So that's potentially part of
the reason for why this is
different from this.
If again, if you're looking at
the practical thing of what
somebody would do when they do
these kind of locally hired
para-teachers, which is this
isn't just made up for some
academic point.
This is happening around the
world a lot, because
governments can't afford
to double the number of
government teachers.
So a lot of what they're doing
in a lot of places is you have
shiksha mitras in
India, you have
para-teachers across Africa.
People who are hired, not
tenured, and often have more
roots in the local community.
AUDIENCE: And they're
paid less?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
A lot, lot, lot less.
So these guys are paid a lot
less than these guys.
So you're right.
You're changing a few things
from this to this, and they're
doing better.
And is it because they're
paid less?
I doubt it's directly because
they're paid less.
But this is a relevant package
is I guess what I'm saying.
This is a relevant package
that a lot of
countries are exploring.
And you're right, it could be
some link to a local area,
although a lot of people in
Kenya, they will be allocated
by the central government, but
they will request to go to if
not their exact community,
to their general area.
And interesting, shiksha
mitras in India are
theoretically controlled by
the local community, but
actually the money comes from
the state government at least.
And they don't show up any more
than regular teachers do.
And they are literally
from the community.
So it doesn't seem to have
helped that much in India.
So again, you can just split
this and look at it, is the
government teacher versus the
contract teacher better in
different situations or
other situations?
Are they particularly better for
low performing kids or for
high performing kids?
And that you can only do though
if you've got-- if the
55, remember we've got
55 in each of these.
So when we pooled them, we have
a lot more statistical
power than if we try and--
where I'm just doing one box
versus another box, I don't
have a lot of statistical
power.
So you have to think at the
beginning exactly how--
do you really want to tease
out those real detailed
questions, or am I OK with the
general pooling of government
versus contract teachers?
So that's an example of--
two different examples,
Balsakhi, where we tried to
answer all these questions with
changing one treatment.
So the benefits of these
cross-cutting treatments is
you can explicitly test these
more specific questions.
You can also explicitly test
interactions if you do it in a
cross-cutting, as opposed to
one experiment here that
reduces class size, one
experiment here that has
contract teachers.
If you do it all in one place,
you can see, does it work
better if I pile all of them
on together, or if it works
better with this particular
subgroup?
And often, you can economize
on data collection because
you're doing one survey, and
changing different things.
And as long as you keep a handle
and keep it straight,
there's a lot of piloting of the
questionnaire, which you
only have to do once.
And maybe you only have to stick
one RA and you hope that
they cover 330 schools instead
of 100, but you only have to
pay one salary.
So the problem is that
when you've got a
cost-cutting design--
so a cross-cutting is this,
where we're using all of the--
we're looking at government
teachers versus contract
teachers across these different
groups, versus
across these different groups.
The negative is that I'm looking
at a contract teacher
versus a government teacher.
In the background, some of those
classes are streamed
versus not streamed.
It should all fall out in the
wash, because these have
streamed as well.
So to the extent that streaming
has an effect, it
has an equal effect
in these two.
And whenever you do an
evaluation, some of the
schools that you're working
in will have
some particular approach.
Some of the schools you're
working in will have a
different approach.
And you're changing across the
schools, say the balance of
half the schools will be
Catholic schools, and half the
schools will be government
schools, and that's fine,
because that's the world.
Some schools are big, some
schools are small.
But you're introducing your
own differences in the
background, in the
average score.
So if in Kenya, no one else
streamed, no schools streamed,
then you're testing this in an
environment where over half of
your schools are doing something
that Kenyan schools
don't normally do.
So you're still getting a valid
effect of the difference
between contract versus
government teachers, but
you're testing it in an
environment which may be a bit
different, because you're
also doing other things.
So I guess what I'm saying is
layering it in this way of
lots of different things allows
you to answer lots of
questions with a
smaller budget.
But you have to remember that
in the end, some of these
schools don't look like
completely typical Kenyan
schools, because they've
got streaming.
And most Kenyan schools
don't stream.
So you're testing something in
a slightly atypical school.
Is that important or is
it not important?
How important a concern
is that to you?
It's all about trade offs.
Stratification, 10 minutes
to do stratification.
The point of stratifying,
you've done your little
exercise on stratification
in your cases?
So you should understand
it all.
That's fine.
The point of it is to give
yourself extra confidence,
extra chance, a higher chance
than normal of making sure
that your treatment and
comparison groups are the same
on anything you can measure.
It's particularly important when
you have a small sample.
You did your little exercise,
and so your bars go up and
down, right?
If you have a really big sample,
it doesn't give you
that much extra power, extra
benefit, because they're going
to be balanced anyway.
Law of large numbers, if you
draw enough times, it's going
to be balanced anyway.
What is it?
Sometimes people get really
stressed out about what am I
stratifying on?
That's not the most important
thing that you're going to
learn here in what
you stratify on.
I would encourage you to
stratify, but if you can't,
again, it doesn't bias you, it
doesn't give you the wrong
answer, but it just helps
on the margin.
And sometimes that margin, as
they say, we've discovered to
our great relief, it saved our
bacon when you're really on
the edge of not having
enough sample.
So all it is is dividing your
sample into different buckets
before you do your
randomization.
That's all it is.
So it's a very simple concept.
It's not always simple
to do, but it's
a very simple concept.
Instead of putting everyone into
one hat and pulling out
of one hat, you divide it into
different hats and then draw
half of each hat.
That's all we're
talking about.
So you select treatment and
control from each of the
subgroups, so you make
sure that you're
balanced on each shore.
So what happens if you
don't stratify?
What could go wrong if
you don't stratify?
What's the danger if
AUDIENCE: You're taking a risk
that some particular group
don't get into the sample.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you're taking a risk that
maybe more of your treatment
ends up being richer
than your control.
And that was the whole point
of randomizing, was to make
sure that they were equal.
And if you have a big enough
sample, you'll be OK, they
will be equal.
But you risk it going wrong.
So if you do your pull, and even
though you stratified it
for some, or you can't stratify,
you do your pull,
and just by chance you get
a really bad draw.
And when you draw it, your
treatment and comparison look
very different, I would advise
you to draw it again.
And then phone us, and
we'll tell you how to
fix it in the analysis.
Because you do have to do
something funny with you
standard errors, and
that's fine.
But you're really screwed if,
just by chance, you do your
pull and you end up with all the
rich guys in one treatment
and all the poor guys
in another.
Then you're done.
Then your evaluation isn't
going to work.
This is statistics, right?
It's on chance, and by chance
you just might get
a really bad pull.
This is stacking the decks
to make sure it doesn't.
If you do that and you see that
it's just screwed, as I
say, I would pull again.
Onto a different thing.
So when should you stratify?
You should stratify on the
variables that have an
important impact on your
outcome variable.
If you're trying to improve
incomes, then it's income at
the beginning.
Or you're trying to improve
education, and it's test
scores at the beginning,
those are going
to be critical things.
If it's something totally
irrelevant, then you don't
need to stratify it.
So the most important thing
is your outcome.
Stratify on subgroups
that you're
particularly interested in.
Say you're really interested
in what's the effect of the
program on the poor, or the
originally low achieving, or
does this work for the Muslim
minority, make sure you have
enough Muslims in your treatment
and control,
otherwise you're not
going to be able
to answer that question.
As I say, if you got a huge
sample, you'll find we're
virtually never in that
situation, but it's
particularly important to do
it when you have a small
sample set, or where your power
is weak, and then it can
just-- it's not going to help
you enormously, but it just
might push you over
the threshold to
getting enough power.
It starts getting very
complicated to do if you try
and stratify on everything.
You're both income and gender,
and you can imagine there may
be some buckets that don't
have any people in them.
So it starts getting
very complicated.
It also makes it less
transparent.
It's very hard to do a
complicated stratification and
do a public draw.
It's very easy to do a
simple one, you just
literally have two hats.
Divide it into two hats and then
you do the draw from the
urban places and do a draw from
the rural, and everyone
can understand that.
If you're trying to do urban
and rural and rich and poor
and whatever, then nobody is
going to understand what
you're doing with all
these 15 different
hats, and it's a mess.
So usually when we stratify,
we do it on the computer.
Again, if you do a public draw,
you can't redraw if it
turns out wrong.
Increasingly we don't
do public draws.
You can stratify on
index variables.
You can put lots of things
into an index and then
stratify on that
if you want to.
So mechanics, how do
I actually do this?
This is a comment from earlier
courses, like we talked all
about it, but how do I
do a random drawing?
We talk about hats, and you
could do it in a hat, but we
don't normally do it.
The first and really important
thing for designing your
evaluation is you can only do
a random draw from a list.
You have to start with a list.
And sometimes that's actually
practically quite hard to do,
because you don't have
a list of all the
people in the community.
You have to go and get a
list, there's really no
other way to do it.
People will talk about--
and people do this when they do
a random draw to interview
people for doing a survey, to
make sure you get a random
sample-- you're surveying a
random sample of people in the
community, they'll talk about
go to the center of the
village, walk along the street
and take every other person.
Not a fan of that, because
actually when people have done
that for us, it's not a random
sample, because they never get
to the outlaying.
And as we all know, the people
who live in the outlaying
parts of the community are very
different from the people
who live at the center of the
community, so you really
basically need to get a list.
And that's expensive.
But you either use a census,
or the list of kids in the
school, or a list
of schools from
the Ministry of Education.
And that we know can take a lot
of heartache and time to
persuade them to hand
over those lists, or
you go and do a census.
Often we've just had to go and
count people, list people, get
the eligible people, write a
list, and then draw from that.
So how can you do it?
You could literally pull it
out of a hat or a bucket.
I keep talking about hats and
buckets because it's very easy
to visualize what
you're doing.
It's transparent, but it's
time consuming and it's
complicated if you have
large groups, and
it's hard to stratify.
So what do we normally do?
Well, you could use a random
number generation in a
spreadsheet program,
and you order the
observations randomly.
Did you do an exercise where
you actually did this?
OK, so why am I talking
to you about this?
So I'm just going to
go through it.
So you can use Excel to do this,
and it's much better if
you go over it in your groups
and do it, or you can run a
Stata program.
Did you do a Stata program
in your groups?
No.
But we can provide
people with--
so I don't know, how many people
here have used Stata?
So this is a program, a
statistical program, that
economists tend to use.
So the people who
are familiar--
I wouldn't advise you to do it
this way if you're not used to
using Stata.
But if you're used to using
Stata, you know about it, but
you just haven't done pulling
a random sample from Stata,
then we can just show you some
code examples and you could
build off those.
For people who haven't done
that, it's really perfectly
possible to do it in Excel, as
long as you don't get too
complicated in your
stratification.
We are also, I hope, going to
be setting up a help desk in
the near future for people who
have attended this course.
We're always available anyway
for people who've attended the
course to come and--
I'm doing this, you remember you
talked about this, and I'm
stuck because it's a bit more
complicated than I thought I
understood it.
But we're going to actually
formalize that process, and
that would mean that if you need
help actually doing it,
you can come to us and
ask us, can you just
check my Stata code?
Can you check that I'm doing
this right in Excel?
Because you don't want
to screw that up.
And we'll have a team of
graduate students or the kind
of the people who are here TAing
who will go over that
and make sure that you--
because we would hate for the
sake of a rusty nail that the
horseshoe falls off and the
kingdom is lost and stuff.
If for the sake of getting your
stratification or your
random pull right, it's worth if
you want someone to have a
double check of that and make
sure that you're doing it,
that you're happy with it.
Because if you get it wrong,
then that invalidates all the
rest of your work.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you stratify,
aren't you compromising on the
randomness?
PROFESSOR: No, because within
groups you are randomizing.
So all you're saying is I
could randomly pull--
I could take all of this group
and randomly draw some of you
to come to the dinner tonight,
and some not to.
Or I could say I want
to make sure that we
have at least half--
equivalent numbers of
men and women as
we have in the course.
And then I'd get all the men
over on one side, and all the
women over the other, and I
would draw half of the men and
half of the women.
So it's still random.
There's still equal chance of
getting picked, I'm just
making sure that I get
proportionate.
So in the microfinance example
where I said we got extra
powers, we got communities,
and we linked them up, we
paired them as close as possible
to each other.
And then within pairs, one was
treatment and one was control.
So we always knew that there was
somebody who looked almost
identical to that community
in the other bucket.
There was always a control that
was almost identical, and
that meant that we just got
less variation than
we would have had.
Otherwise, less variation
gives you
more statistical power.
But everyone had an equal chance
of being in, we're just
stacking the decks to make
sure that they were as
comparable as possible.
Because when you draw randomly,
by chance they could
not be comparable.
But if you literally pair them
and switch one versus another,
you are sure that there'll be a
control that looks very much
like the treatment.
And you don't get the chance
case that you just happened to
get all the rich communities in
the treatment and all the
poor communities
in the control.
With the stratifying, you have
to take that into account when
you do your analysis.
So you just put in a dummy
variable, those people who are
actually going to run the
regression at the end, you
need to put in a dummy
variable for each
strata that you did.
AUDIENCE: What's the cost
of stratification?
PROFESSOR: So that
is the one cost.
You have to put in a dummy
in every case.
So as I say, it gets quite
complicated to do it
when you have lots.
The main--
AUDIENCE: And you cut
a degree of freedom?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you lose
a degree of freedom.
AUDIENCE: You lose power?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So there's been a long esoteric
debate in the
econometrics, amongst the
serious econometricians over
the last year about whether you
can decide not to put the
dummy in the end.
I think the conclusion is that
you have to decide in advance
whether you're going
to put your dummy.
So basically, you just have to
put your dummy variables in.
So you do lose a degree
of freedom.
The argument was, maybe then
you could be worse off.
Someone did a whole bunch
of simulations.
They proved that you could
potentially be worse off.
Nobody has been able, even in a
simulation, to come up with
an example whether you were
actually worse off.
But you lost more power
than you gained.
But if you remember my advice
to you was to do it on the
ones that are likely to be
important, and that is because
potentially there is a
theoretical possibility you
could over-stratify, because you
could lose some degrees of
freedom at the end, because you
have to put in a dummy for
something that didn't actually
help you reduce variance.
But as I say, even someone who
is trying to prove this case
did a bunch of simulations and
couldn't find a single example
where they actually
ended up with less
power through stratify.
So my gut from this, and
especially after having done
the microfinance one was
on the whole, I would--
now the main constraint is you
normally don't have a lot of
information before you start.
If you've done your baseline
before you randomize, you have
a ton of information.
Then you can stratify
on anything
you have in the baseline.
If you randomize before your
baseline, you probably don't
know very much about
these communities,
and it's pretty hard.
But if you're randomizing
after you've done your
baseline, and it entered and
cleaned, basically in order to
do that, you have to delay
your implementation for
several months after you've
done your baseline.
If you want to do you
implementation immediately
you've done your baseline,
you're probably not going to
have that many variables
entered.
And then you just have to
stratify on what variables you
have entered or cleaned
or whatever.
So that's usually the
constraint, that you don't
have much information on
which to stratify.
That's really what it comes
down to usually.
OK, I went over a bit,
but any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I just have one
question-- more of a
clarification-- but it goes
back to the questions--
the different levels of
questions that you asked.
So were those questions that the
client came to you with?
Or did the client come to you
and say, we have a program, we
want to know if it works?
And then as you were talking
with them, the different
layers came out because
you realized you're
doing all this stuff?
PROFESSOR: So if you remember
where I talked about in terms
of when do you do an evaluation,
I talked about
different possibilities.
And one was you have to program,
that you want to test
the program, and that was
the Balsakhi case.
And they had this program, they
wanted to test it, and
the researchers used the fact
that the program did some
things, and that some of the
things affected some kids and
not other kids to tease out some
interesting questions.
In the extra teacher provision
case, it was more like where I
said, you want to know
some questions?
Set up a field site and just go
experiment the hell out of
it so that you can find out what
the hell's going on, and
you understand these deep
parameters that then you could
go off and design.
So the extra teacher program
was really that.
It was saying there are these
fundamental questions in
education that we don't
know the answer to.
And we're going off the
literature in the US where
they've done lots of
experiments, but we don't know
if that's relevant to
these countries.
So those are important questions
to lots of people
around the world.
Let's find out what
the answers to--
it wasn't really a very--
it was an NGO program, but it
was mainly done for these
research purposes, and these
more general policy purposes.
And it was paid for not by the
NGO, the evaluation wasn't
paid for by the NGO.
But it was, I think, relevant.
As I say, it is a relevant
policy package, because the
reason they did it was not just
of academic interest to
see does class size matter,
but governments around the
world are worrying about whether
to hire more teachers,
and should they hire them as
government teachers or
contract teachers?
There isn't actually much
discussion in the policy world
about the streaming.
But given our other findings
about how the curricula is so
over the head of other kids,
and the tentative findings
from Balsakhi that it really
looked like focusing--
the lower performing kids seemed
to do better being
pulled out, that was the
motivation for saying, well,
actually maybe this is something
that's relevant in
other cases.
And I think it's more that that
then raises the question,
and then people are starting to
think about it, rather than
that streaming really was a
big question in the policy
context of Kenya at the time.
And the ETP one, I should say,
that's probably one of our
most complicated.
Don't look at that complicated
diagram of all the different
things that were being tested
and multiple treatments.
That's kind of one of the most
complicated designs we've ever
done, so that's not like we're
expecting everyone to go out
of here, or go off and do
something like that.
But it was just kind of the
extreme of this is the
potential that you could
potentially get at.
OK, thanks.